let's bring in Michael Wilbon will be
from pardon the interruption in by the
way he's a northwestern grad
morale has got to be hi Michael how you
feeling today I've never been hired a
day okay
alright now is there scenario where
Northwestern story would surpass the
Cubs winning the World Series in your
world sure of course I mean that they
have to you know for starters I guess
beat Gonzaga tomorrow which is a huge
order considering we're talking about a
number one fee but yeah I mean they if
no less than beacons AGGA tomorrow and
it's getting to the final four that's
the scenario about which northwestern
could surpass the Cubs and given in
college basketball is this enormous
thing for one month if that somehow
happened and I think the next game then
likely would be against Notre Dame I
mean you get these series of
high-profile games and and you know
Northwestern we've already played and
lofted Notre Dame at the buzzer engineer
wants yeah so that beating them is more
likely than beating comes Agra obviously
but you have to becomes active to get to
them so yeah yeah that that that could
happen are we there yet no but if you
ask me what's more unlikely northwestern
getting to the Final Four or the Cubs
winning the World Series at the
beginning of the era said northwestern
getting to the Final Four what were you
thinking in that you know final 15
seconds when all of a sudden you know
there's a an intentional foul and then
yeah like it was a bizarre sequence I
don't know if we'll talk about this the
way we did Freddie brown or Chris
Weber's timeout but right it was one of
those moments on a big stage where
everybody saw it what did you think I
did you're not into it I mean I'm six
rows from the floor and I was right
behind a Northwestern bench and you
could see the surprise in the faces of
the northwestern kids like what did this
kid just do for Vanderbilt
what just happened here and the shock in
their faces
you know they know they got a score
there they got a you know really draw a
foul or score to win the game you need I
expect and that guy's just gonna put you
on the line with 14 seconds left now the
one thing was Vanderbilt was going to
get the ball back which they did but
still it's just you know but Dan you
know this you watch so many of these
game for so many years and what you
reminded of is their kids yeah their
kids they're there they they're not pros
some of them go on to be pros and as we
know even the ones who want to be pros
you know rarely as rookies look like
composed you know men and their kids and
they I watch these games and you see
that you see so many mistakes you know
and you love the college game for the
drama that it has and and and for the
jerseys you root and and all of that but
for people who think that the college
game is anywhere near the pro game
they're insane and it's not supposed to
be but you get reminded of this even in
the tournament even when you've got you
know allegedly the best whatever number
of teams in the country and so you're
sitting there going oh my god I can't
believe this just happened and I feel I
feel terribly for the Vanderbilt player
who they're not even in the game without
that kid yes I don't want to hear
anybody I mean he yeah he by himself in
the second half just shocked him and by
the way you look at him and you saying
my god
this kid's gonna play this this kid is
gonna be a pro but right now he's a
sophomore college I did I feel for him
he's Michael Wilbon from pardon the
interruption joining us Dan Patrick show
I want you to judge this because you
know come tournament time there are a
lot of people a lot of gas bags
blowhards like us who make it seem like
they've been following college
basketball all year long there is a
there's an art to being able to talk
about a matchup without mentioning any
real specifics so Polly would you just
you know put on display for Michael
Wilbon somebody who knows nothing about
college basketball but gives the
impression he knows everything about a
matchup you know North West are not a
traditional team going this deep into
the tournament but a scrappy bunch they
play hard like a Big Ten team should but
they're going against a big boy Gonzaga
former mid-major but now at the top of
the heap this should be a great one
[Laughter]
that's a nice little thumbnail that
there's nothing yeah it sounded like you
did
it sounded like you did it also by the
way it's but I prefer that one Dan to
where people start naming names and
people and where they're from they try
to act a phony and go the other way
let's start giving you a bunch of
metrics it's like okay shut up Steve
Alford if you were Steve Alford and
Indiana called
what would you do no no I this is great
cuz I did talk about this I mean
obviously this is a beautiful big head
story and they're putting a big 10
people where I am right now here in Salt
Lake City this tournament we did we
talked quite a bit about Steve Alford I
talked to some coaches about it and look
I'll always understand the draw home
always but I gotta wait and see how this
plays out at the very least all you
would you can't you know you're not
gonna interrupt this this run yeah Wow
if they if they win at UCLA I mean you
know I mean the greatest Hoosier of them
all he stayed at UCLA I mean Steve
Alford is a disappears right in
somewhere right now our offer talks
about knowing as a little child that the
great John Wooden was a Hoosier yeah he
went away to UCLA to make his you know
makes you the name and there's no
greater name you know I can I understand
the pull of home but but I don't know
what's bigger in the universe Indiana or
UCLA I feel think it's UCLA even being a
big thing Midwestern kid and a
neighboring state kid and maybe part of
me just doesn't want to see offers
coming back to make Indiana that good
again although although they were just
that good I mean Crane had them being
that good you know Crean already had
Indiana being that good again and that
and he fell off his perch but I don't
know damn well I ever heard you weigh in
on this year what do you what do you
think I should do I think you should
stay at UCLA yeah me too yeah i but you
know these are true legendary places of
franchises teams universe i I understand
all of that but sometimes it's home is
not everything it's made out to be you
know they if you go back and you don't
succeed it's impossible this is awful
feeling is rotten in a way that it
wouldn't be if he didn't succeed at UCLA
I know you didn't say yeah I think you
and I agree on this I know you've been
passionate about this with the topic you
and Tony talked about Georgetown with
John Thompson the third and you know
people asking about his his future
during press conferences and being shut
down
we had Patrick Ewing on first hour and I
said you know if they called you would
you would you be interested in he said
well I would listen but I want to be a
head coach in the NBA but yes it's my
alma mater but I hope JT 3 you know gets
in puts another chance what you know
separate your emotion if you can and you
know what's your Georgetown do in this
situation this is you know what Dan this
is a really difficult one I think nobody
wants to be measured about this but I
was covering Georgetown when a lot of
this set up what we're looking at now
and when Big John had that program
roaring and it was as important as any
program in the country
Georgetown made some decisions a series
of decisions about what basketball with
the place basketball was going to hold
in that universities culture and in the
culture of just Catholic higher
education and one of the reasons I
always admired Georgetown I have no ties
other than I covered the team for a lot
of years they made a conscious decision
they did you know building a stadium
building on campus arena which is gonna
be difficult
giving given you know how its shoehorned
into one of the great you know urban
locations in America there was gonna be
a lot of space but they they decided
consciously as I recall not to build an
arena yes if we got a week we have a
downtown arena we've got we can use
whatever it was called at the time back
back in the day looking downtown
Capital Center for crying out loud dingy
old 25 miles away Capital Center now
it's whatever it's three miles away or
two miles away and it doesn't work and
the school made this choice what's the
large what's the big difference between
right now Villanova and Georgetown
Villanova built that place on campus and
I don't think Georgetown came the the
the model for college basketball change
you look at the similarities between
DePaul
Georgetown st. John's what what do those
three schools not have they don't have
campus modern on-campus gymnasium and
and and Dan I applaud Georgetown and Big
John for what they did they said look
here's our place this is what we believe
in these are our priorities as an
institution of higher learning
institution and I I applaud them I
admire them for that but then when you
given that win them when the model for
the basketball program
evolves and you don't have that and you
get left behind and you asked your
current coach whether it's a series of
coaches at DePaul or jt3 okay now you
need to do this you know what Dan and I
look I'm friendly with John socially in
Washington and you know my wife grew up
with him and I and I root for jt3 but I
don't I don't know that anybody can do
what those schools want to happen
anymore without that new model of
basketball maybe some people would say
you're wrong it can happen I don't
believe it I believe that you have to go
the way Villanova and they didn't do it
and now you can't I'm told if that it's
a zoning matter there's no way you can
put on campus arena in there and do I
think that's the only thing maybe yeah I
mean - Paul yeah they're building an
arena dan that's like 20 miles the other
way south away from the arena that's 20
miles wouldn't campus now that's north
and I'm talking about this last night
this you have a chance when you're
around college bad walk people just run
over all these issues and DePaul
basketball you know this because you
grew up with the Paul being arrival of
Dayton DePaul basketball was bigger in
the 1970s and 80s than Bulls basketball
in Chicago yeah and where did it go and
so is it one coach's fault was it Joey
Myers fault really Joey Meyer who's
calling the the northwestern games by
the way he's right here I mean he's a
great person to ask about this but I
just think the JT I think they're asking
some of the daughters have good enough
so Bert
and then sort of reproduced maybe I'm
wrong but I definitely the way I see it
right now have fun good luck tomorrow
and hold on to that voice there Michael
it's it's going going going
I'm gonna do television tomorrow dancer
I got it I got to come up with a Dan
Patrick remedy text me any throat
remedies you may have between now and
tomorrow whiskey even when I don't have
a sore throat thank you Michael
thank the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience